a man takes one last sip of whiskey he
gets in his car and drives to his
favorite place Glenwood Canyon he
arrives parks his car takes out a
flashlight and a car registration from
the glove box and then unscrews his
license plate he throws his registration
and license plate into the river as he
walks to a particular spot he and his
wife would always spend time at when she
was still alive it's one of the highest
points of the canyon and it has an
incredible view of the valley beneath it
he has come to commit suicide the man
stands at the edge of the canyon
thinking one last time about his life he
looks out at the massive beautiful
landscape the night sky sprinkled with
stars seamlessly converges with the
stone of the canyons edge as it trips
down into the river beneath he feels a
combination of wonder and pain as he's
admiring the landscape a woman's voice
behind him yells hey startled the man
almost falls but then catches himself he
turns around to find a woman appearing
out of the forest she wears a long dress
and has long silvery straight hair she's
old but sort of pretty it's late and
dark and the man wonders why she's here
by herself she approaches the man and
says hello kind of confused and thrown
off the man says hello back what are you
doing here so late by yourself the man
asks in kind of a snarky way the woman
responds with the same question what are
you doing here so late by herself again
thrown off the man says I don't know I
guess I just needed to clear my head
this is my favorite spot you're awfully
close to the edge of that cliff to be
clear in your head replies the woman are
you going to jump no like I said I'm
just here to clear my head I've had a
long couple of days
says the man okay well have a good night
says the woman she begins to walk away
this confuses the man he had quickly
constructed a fantasy in his head that
this woman was some deity type who
appeared by faith to save him to
convince him not to jump to change his
mind about life as the woman walks away
the man calls out a way he never said
why you're here the woman turns around
you never said why you're here
replies the woman yes I did I just told
you the man says with a nervous guilty
laugh the woman gets really close to the
man quickly moving from where she was
right up into the man's face why are you
really here she whispers
the man thrown off yet again stutters
I'm clearing my [ __ ] head okay why
don't you believe me the woman turns
around and begins to walk away again as
she begins to walk further away the man
panics at the thought of the woman
leaving without trying to save him he
yells out okay fine I'm here to jump the
woman turns around pardon
she asks I'm here to kill myself this
life is awful and I'm ready to die okay
there you go the woman comes back to
where the man standing what's so awful
about it she asks what's not so awful
about it replies the man it's filled
with ugliness and sadness there's
tragedy there's conflict as heartbreak
it's endlessly difficult for no reason
success is hard there's no obvious
meaning to anything even just the little
things the traffic the cold weather the
Mondays the way the grocery stores are
lit in the god-awful cashiers that
always look at you like they'd be better
off if you weren't alive
well what life would you not want to
jump from ask the woman a life without
all that obviously says the man a life
filled with only beauty happiness love
and peace a life that's easy and fun all
the time one where there's a parent
meaning to stuff and we actually know
what's going on and why we're here and
what the point is one with no heartbreak
no tragedy no conflict no hardship no
mean grocery store cashier is no traffic
no Monday's no pain hmm
says the woman everything would be
perfect and I would never want to leave
that life says the man the man and the
woman stare at each other for a second
it feels like a few so who are you you
have to tell me why you're here now the
man agitatedly asks again the woman
moves closer to him I'm who you hoped I
was confused the man backpedals a little
bit completely forgetting where he's
standing what do you mean asked the man
the woman leans in to answer and pushes
the man softly on his chest he falls
backwards off the cliff
[Music]
the man awakes in his bedroom it's a
normal Tuesday morning he thinks about
how horrible the nightmare he just had
was but like most dreams he quickly
forgets and moves on he gets out of bed
and gets ready he gets dressed eats
breakfast and leaves his house the sky
is bright pink and purple with a sunny
glow that illuminates the whole world
the grass is richly green and smells
like the first spring to ever take place
in the universe the birds harmonized
together perfectly
every person is smiling cheek to cheek
as if their faces are pinned in such a
position
the man is entirely happy he has no
sense of sadness everything is beautiful
with no sight of ugliness the world has
no conflicts everyone loves each other
equally
there's no heartbreak no hardship no bad
days no traffic no mean grocery store
cashiers life is easy and smooth and fun
the meaning of life and the nature of
reality is clear and everyone knows
exactly what's going on it's completely
and entirely perfect a year or so goes
by the man is at home he takes one last
sip of water he gets in his car and
drives to gladwyn Canyon it's not too
far from where he lives he parks his car
takes out a flashlight and the car
registration from the glove box and then
unscrews his license plate he throws his
registration and license plate into the
river as he walks to a spot that's one
of the highest points of the canyon he
has come to commit suicide he stands at
the edge of the canyon thinking about
his life one last time he looks out at
the massive beautiful landscape the
night skies for coolest are seamlessly
converges with the stone of the canyons
edge as it trips down into the river
beneath he feels nothing he's about to
jump when a woman's voice from behind
them yells hey startled the man almost
falls but catches himself he turns
around to find a woman appearing out of
the forest
this woman's presence is not interesting
or perplexing to the man she approaches
the man it says hello and asks him what
he's doing I'm going to jump says the
man why asks the woman it's a waste
being alive isn't it there's nothing to
do everything is easy and boring I want
to feel but there's nothing to feel
answers the man well what life would you
not want to jump from asks the woman a
life that's interesting and exciting and
actually has feeling obviously replies
the man well what makes a life that way
the woman I don't know one where some
stuff is beautiful but not everything or
perhaps everything is beautiful but at
least you don't always notice it so you
can actually appreciate it when you do a
life you're happy some of the time but
not all the time and some of the time
you actually feel really sad so you can
tell the difference one where everyone
doesn't love each other and some people
aren't really that nice at all so you
can actually feel special about certain
people when we're bad stuff happens once
in a while one where things are actually
kind of hard and finding success and
meaning requires some thought effort and
creativity so it actually feels
important when you find it one where
nothing is ever perfect but some stuff
can get really close if you try hard
enough I never want to leave that life
doesn't it sound wonderful
asks the man yes says the woman it does
the man turns around to look at the
landscape over the cliff and try to
imagine a life like that
the woman leans in and pushes him softly
on the back he falls forward off the
cliff hope you see at this time the
woman says to herself
[Music]
you